article from army times
foreboding army psyops recruitment video
shows who's pulling the strings a lot of
people were bringing us up to us saying
it was a really really creepy video i
want to play it is a little long but
i've not seen it
but daniel was just bringing up that the
cia intelligence agencies get so much
wrong and i wonder are they really
getting it wrong or are they just trying
to manipulate you
perhaps you assume that they're a bunch
of bumbling slipping on banana peels and
maybe that's what they want you to think
because what sun tzu had quotes about
this right when you're strong make your
enemy believe you are weak when you're
weak make your own enemy believe you are
strong so i've i've never seen this
i don't know if we can play the full
thing but we'll play ghosts in the
machine a controversial psychological
operations advertisement from the army
is there something nice
if your opponent is of choleric temper
seek to irritate him that sounds like
sun
pretend to be weak that he may grow
arrogant you see my man sun
tzu all right this is getting pretty
creepy about that guy
oh clowns
strong start have you ever wondered
in china
[Music]
who's pulling the strings
hiding nearby
[Music]
whispering
born from the ashes
is that the emblem of the psychological
operation a world at war
you will find us in the shadows
this is inspiring
at the tip of the spear
[Music]
[Music]
russia invades ukraine
it's pretty new yeah yeah this is from
uh earlier this month
warfare is evolving who put this out
uh this is a fourth psyop group
i am intrigued and all the world's a
stage yo this is creepy
it's like a movie shakespeare
there is another very important phase of
warfare
it has as its target
not the body
but the mind of the enemy
the target of psychological warfare is
against the enemy's mind
it is words and ideas ammunition used by
cyborg
anything we touch
is a weapon
its mission is to influence the thoughts
of the people we can deceive
human experience gripping
at my skin
the walls of night closing come in many
forms
but the use of this force as an integral
part of combat has now taken on new form
we are everywhere
that's what they want you to think
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a feeling in the dark
[Applause]
a message of the stars
ghosts in the machine
what are we
say war what the heck what is this
really it who put that together army
psyops recruitment video that's what
they're saying really i don't want to
know that's interesting
so i can respond to that silliness uh
okay
it's all fake it's all boring oh my god
okay a couple times
i would join right now right now
i'll tell you i i
i was we get by that is to say in the
intelligence community folks get by with
this kind of stuff everybody thinks that
you know until people are 10 feet tall
and they're scary and amazing do
anything they want james bond
but i'm telling you that ain't how it is
all right uh i
and and i can share this story with you
um i was looking to work with our group
of folks who go out into the world and
hire knox right those are people that we
would never officially recognize as
intelligence officers
and i asked our knock hiring
officials
what do you look for
and
she said to me we don't look for the f
students obviously or the d students as
it were sort of a b c d f the grades
right d or f students those don't those
kids don't wouldn't work
but
we can't hire a and b
because they're too good and smart and
they don't want to put up with the
bureaucratic baloney that this place has
so what we have to try to find is like a
good solid c-plus student that's me
so yeah
you sir well i'll put a good word for
you you know since i'm still a fed i am
i i i think it actually is just like the
movies because you know i've i've seen a
lot of burn notice yeah and yeah you do
look and talk like michael is that right
okay so no matter what i say
so they want people that are not so
adherent to authority that they'll get
a's and b's because that's what they're
told to do but they're not so stupid
that they aren't can't follow along it's
that they're willing to join but they're
also willing to betray amb students are
after they have ambition uh but they
want efficiency they want
accomplishments they want it's um
you can go out into the private sector
and earn a ton of money you can go be
successful as your a and b students but
your c student they tend to struggle
more in life so you need somebody that
isn't quite
tip of the spear as that video just said
right so that's what but that shouldn't
be true by the way we should want a
students
and b students working for our
government because we we want efficiency
we want smarts we want the best we can
get
so i i don't buy that video because of
that having been on the inside um
but i understand why people might think
that that's true the only other quick
caveat i'd add is um
there is one part of me that loves that
because when i was out as an officer i
was meeting with a source
and he
was like why aren't you taking notes i'm
telling you all these great amazing
things well i didn't need to i was able
to capture it and he and he paused he's
like wait a minute
obviously in the movies
do you have a microphone in your shoe
and i was like
i do
was a cool show man
one of my favorite scenes is when
you guys have seen bernardus right
negative gnome you never seen it it's so
good so it's this former cia contractor
and he's always trying to he's basically
a contractor now for private individuals
trying to help the little guy
and he explains to you how he does
things and why
and it's fascinating so he's like he's
trying to scare a bad guy so he takes a
cell phone tapes it to a box and then
runs the power cable to the wall to make
him think there's a bomb and he was like
that's like the psychological
manipulation stuff so that's what this
show does i love that show it's amazing
so i what i will tell you that this
contracting thing is actually really
important so we just watch if this is
the army's trying to convince everybody
that they're the 10-foot monster if you
want to talk about power and the
authority to influence and persuade
that power does not sit within the
military and it doesn't sit within the
cia it sits in hollywood it sits in new
york and in dc in terms of those media
operating rooms deciding what what the
editorial line for the day is going to
be what the american people need to
think about it's the people who write
the headlines knowing that 70 80 of
people don't read the story just the
headline that's your power if you want
to shape an agenda if you want to push
people into believing something
that's where you spend your time and
your money it ain't some whiz-bang you
know cia operation that's propaganda
which by the way that was good back in
the 50s and it's not so great now but
anyway
that's where your power is one thing
about the video if we could ask your
your huge followers i feel like i'm
pretty well traveled in this country i
can't think of what city has bright
orange subway cars
so if anything yeah all of your
followers right now if you could be like
oh yeah that's the subway in
i showed it twice and i'm like i know
america pretty well i've i grew up in
new york city i know subways well i
can't think so if i don't i don't went
out there it's not so much the color or
the shape of them maybe it wasn't an
american city but i will say i learned
something in my quest to purchase times
square billboards you can actually buy
your an entire train and put whatever
you want on it let's do that yeah
i would just love to think that the army
used like uh the subway of of amsterdam
yeah for a recruitment video
i've been thinking a lot about
using the media like you were saying too
i guess manipulate is the word not you
know it sounds like people are saying
someone said japan oh interesting
maryland i saw denmark oh the people
were saying whatever yeah they're just
saying whatever
like how do you use the media to please
everyone and i know you can't please
everyone all the time abraham lincoln
quote but like i want to really make the
world better and create new technologies
like running fresh water uh solar
powered heat you know things that will
make us more resilient as a species make
people laugh make people relax like even
the the head of the cia and kim jong-un
want to laugh and relax a little bit but
i also got to make sure people have
enough food
i don't know if there's people that
actually want to starve the population
so that it grows slower you hear about
bill gates talking about reducing the
growth rate
and i don't know if there are people
that that really want that which seems
crazy
other than that like you i do you think
we could we could actually use the media
i mean that it's possible well look are
there people in this world who have a
particular agenda for the environmental
issue or the global population or
whatever and then they use their money
to affect that outcome damn straight and
we have foundations in this country all
over the world in fact the united states
have a massive number of private family
foundations that chase after whatever
their own family's goals might be okay
so it's not it wouldn't be a wild
assumption to hear or or an argument to
hear somebody say this family or this
person really is gets excited about x
issue now they're really going to change
all of our lives just because they and
their big money want to change it so
absolutely there is precedent for that
every day we've got it
um but the the second piece though uh
tell me again it's more of like um i
don't know i'm asking if it's possible i
mean i know you don't have the answer
but you don't think it's possible to fix
this planet bring people together like
all this all of us together yeah and
i'll tell you what it is
real quick as an interrupt uh
watching the ad there's an advertisement
and it looks to be in german oh
interesting
yeah so then it was made by the army in
the subway
so we're talking about the german army
that was putting that out that's a lot a
heck of a lot better that's how good the
psychological warfare is yeah
they kept showing the statue of liberty
that's why i was like they're trying to
make you think it's new york
let's be really honest for a second
europe's military is a joke come on in
ukraine do you recall when things were
bubbling up what did germany offer the
ukrainians 5 000 helmets get out of here
their military is absolutely hollowed
out so
anyway that's ridiculous uh but i will
tell you in terms of the media stuff um
you know how can we shape how can we
encourage how do we grow as a people as
a country as a species whatever it might
be
no joke and i'm not saying it because
i'm here it's this
these kinds of shows are where it
happens because what you do is you
encourage people to think to think for
themselves and to think critically
you give them information and you say
hey look here's my bias here's what i
think here's the data that supports my
argument but i'll tell you what your
call you you decide it's up to you
that's what we have to encourage each
other to do that's what i do in my
podcast that's what you all do here on
this show every day that's how we shape
the world we now control the information
we put it out there and if people trust
us
not just because oh they seem smart but
they but they know that day in and day
out when we talk to them
we say here's the data
you decide here's why it's important to
you but it's your call then people are
less like um what are you trying to do
to me what are you trying to get me to
buy what are you trying to like
manipulate me to think all i'm doing is
saying here's the information here's
what i think but y'all make the call
well that's what's so fascinating about
than the role of of tech right so here's
the data you make the decision i work in
the environmental and energy space and
here's the data that's actually you
don't believe in climate change i'm
de-platformed from facebook you're not
allowed to be a climate denier on
facebook and you say well i'm not
denying anything i'm just saying here's
a set of facts that need to be discussed
not on our platform because you don't
care and what you just said you
sometimes you strike me that you say
some of the sweetest most like like
humanitarian things and you said i make
the world a better place and give you
know solar heat and clean water you know
where they didn't discuss any of that
sentiment if you paid attention the last
couple days was davos
all those world leaders gathered and
they talked about what we will do oh
there's the photos of them i i had to i
had to know confirmed germany berlin all
right
so did we know this that was the
german army that was like joining our
psyops group
i don't know why we were able to filter
on you know who was the last one that
made it during the german army ad
uh yeah from getty images but but anyway
your sentiment of how do we find
solutions to the problems that will make
the world a better more peaceful more
healthy more prosperous place at the
individual level you looked at those
yahoos and davos and all they did was
talk about what can we do to make them
obey how do we cut countries off the
global monetary and banking system if
they won't vaccinate their people and
everyone collapse and john kerry how do
we punish people that will not accept
climate change everyone collapse that
whole thing should have been we should
have built a wall around davos and
forced them to live there and given them
some primitive weapons and hunger games
we gotta thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you